our next guest is the only person let's
say that again the only person ever to
have served as both CIA director and the
Secretary of State during Mike pompeo's
four years in the Trump Administration
he helped spearhead some of former
president Trump's most ambitious foreign
policy objectives he's very proud about
that his new book is called never give
an inch fighting for the America I love
secretary Pompeo we're glad to say joins
us live and in color here in the studio
good to see you Mr great to see you too
yeah great to be back with you you're in
a good mood I'm I'm in a fantastic mood
it's wonderful to be here I'm glad I'm
glad to talk to you but I want to start
with this because it's been such a heavy
day and it seems like we have more and
more of these stories every single day
it breaks my heart it makes me ill we're
talking of course about the mass
shootings there have been 38 mass
shootings across the country so far in
2023 Mr secretary that's more than the
days of the that we've had at the
beginning of the year
what do you think needs to be done and I
know it's not an easy answer but it's
just something that you can tell us
before we move on to your book so I
grappled with this when I was a member
of Congress these are tough problems
there's no easy answer I I think we're
going to find that you know some of
these are in California some of the
toughest gun laws in the exactly country
well you guys were probably possessed
illegally although I think we don't know
all the facts yet I think some of this
is cultural that is we need to make sure
that the families families are intact
that they're good mental health services
available for people that are struggling
there's I wish there was a simple answer
you know I watch not only these mass
shootings but I watch the inner cities
of America being a tough place where
there's kids getting killed every night
we need we need to we need to be an
America that understands that every life
matters and we need to make sure that we
have support for our law enforcement so
they can do their work well and support
for people who are challenged so that we
don't end up with precisely what we've
seen exactly just these last couple they
say all the time nobody wants to take uh
guns from responsible gun owners and the
Second Amendment back then they were
telling about muskets the hardware that
we see on the streets we've got to
figure out a way to do something but
we're not going to solve that here at
this particular time let's talk about
your book because some people view this
book as an opening argument for your
Declaration of presidency of the
presidency what do you say to that no
you said you're considering it how close
are you to making it so as for that
Susan and I are thinking praying trying
to figure out if this is the next place
to go surf but we haven't come to that
conclusion we'll do so how close are you
we'll we'll figure this out in the next
handful of months but that's not why I
wrote this book A book was actually
supposed to be out in August but the
author was tardy in getting the
manuscript completed
I wanted to tell the story from my
perspective for four years of the Trump
Administration and our effort to put the
American people at the front of American
foreign policy how it matters to every
American you know when you talk about
Taiwan or Moscow it seems like a long
ways away but I wanted to share with the
American people that it matters to every
American that we get this right and
America's place in the world matters and
we should defend it vigorously well
president Trump has already announced
that he's going to run again is that
going is that having any any impact on
your decision none none
you don't feel uh
disloyal taking him on if you decide to
run against him oh goodness no when you
run for president you're making the case
to the American people so all the folks
who decide to run on both sides of the
aisle will be presenting themselves
their ideas they'll make arguments I
hope they'll speak in language that is
fundamentally decent and speaks to the
higher higher calling of America and is
an optimistic message so no it won't
matter to the pompeo's who else decides
to run uh what will make that decision
based on whether we think this is our
moment well Nikki Haley also says she's
thinking about running and she comes up
in your book a couple of times and in
the book you say that she she had
reached out to she had strongly hinted
that maybe she had tried to replace Mike
Pence as vice president she denies that
she says that it's a claim and I want to
quote her she calls lies and gossips
that you wrote in your book that you
were trying to sell that when you wrote
that she that you were told that she was
trying to replace Mike Pence's vice
president yeah so that's just you liar
liar pants on fire that that never
happened Chief Kelly told me it was true
I think kellyanne Conway has confirmed
that she thought it was true but I
didn't write about it for that reason
why did you write I wrote I wrote that
that storyline because in the Trump
Administration it was tough uh the the
media was after us they were trying to
create a gap between you and the
president every day they were coming at
all of us pretty hard and so everyone
was saying get out quit run Ambassador
Haley didn't decide to stay she decided
to leave when times were tough and there
were incredibly dangerous places that
America found itself
um so many people on the team didn't
stay and you know for me every day every
day was a privilege to serve I was the
Secretary of State for a thousand days I
wasn't about to give up one single
second of it to focus on anything but
doing my duty to the country but it is
seem to be a lot of fluid with the truth
in the Trump Administration would you
agree with that
I think politicians are prone to that
too often you might even find a time
we'd say oh Mike I'm not sure you quite
were clear I try my best every day and I
did this as Secretary of State too I
tried my best every day to well I see I
director so we had to keep secrets but
apart from that apart from that I tried
my best every day never to say anything
that I did not know to be true and if I
couldn't speak about it I just said I'm
sorry I can't talk we understand the
secrets it's it's the outright lies that
I think many people have problems no
leader should ever do that no leader in
church in a faith institution no leader
at the PTA meeting or school board and
no leader in Washington D.C
in your book you write very little about
January 6 but you did surprise me with
this when you said that January 6 you
described it as a calling it the day
that the left wanted to exploit for a
political Advantage do you really feel
that just yesterday people were
convicted in January 6. well if this is
conspiracy yeah if they commit crimes
they should be convicted although I've
said this for two and a half years now
however long it's been if you committed
crimes if you broke into the capital and
committed violence you should be
prosecuted but but in the book Mr
secretary you described it as a day that
it was just exploited for Democrats it
has been exploited it's absolutely been
exploited by the left I I believe that
firmly we've had we've had bad days in
America before that night ended in glory
that night ended in the United States of
America completing its constitutional
process and confirming President Biden
as the duly elected president of the
United States we should we should be
proud of that and we shouldn't use we
shouldn't use violence in a political
way whether that violence happens in the
streets of Seattle or Minneapolis but
the violence happened because the people
that day that took over the capital
believed that the election had been
stolen yes and many people believe that
they were urged to go to of the capital
to protest the way they did because of
Donald Trump do you believe the election
was stolen no I don't believe the
election was stolen Gail but I do think
we have an enormous confidence Gap with
the American people secretary Clinton
continues to talk about her election as
having not we have we have two now two
consecutive elections and by the way in
2000 we had the hanging Chads you'll
remember that we got to fix this we've
got to run election processes that are
transparent them so that people can have
confidence but Donald Trump is still
saying that have you told him maybe you
should stop saying that I've spoken to
the president he knows exactly what I
think about the election is where we got
it right where I think we got it right
and where we got it wrong and I've never
talked about the election being stolen
can I talk to you about classified
documents because now we have a sitting
president a former president yes
have you looked in your own house do you
have are you worried about maybe they'll
find classified documents at your place
in your gym in your garage and what do
you think about this well I don't have a
Corvette in there yeah uh and so I I
don't think they will but I'd say three
things about this and I write about this
and never give an inch I actually write
about this the book preceded uh these
issues both at Mar-A-Lago and uh in the
president or the president's homes uh if
you have classified documents handle
them correctly and if you find that you
have in the wrong place
I take responsibility take
accountability and turn them back in
thank you Mr secretary